okay today I'm going to talk to you
about transferring energy now all that
this means is when we start off with
energy in one store and then we end up
with energy in another store we're
looking at how to draw diagrams to show
how energy goes from one store to
another and why we need to know the four
different mechanisms by which it does
this so the four different mechanisms we
need to know is first of all
mechanically now whenever we're talking
about the transfer mechanically this is
when forces are involved the second one
we need to know is electrically so this
is whenever we have some kind of charge
moving around a circuit so work is being
done against resistance number three the
other one we need to know is by heating
so this is whenever we've got energy
being transferred from hotter to colder
and finally the fourth one we need to
know is by radiation now this is
whenever we have waves involved now this
might seem a little confusing so what
I'm going to do is going to use examples
free an example for each one in order to
show you what I mean so let's imagine an
example of energy being transferred
mechanically is in a ball falling so we
start off holding the ball high and then
we let it go so what we need to do to
draw one of these diagrams is think
first of all what is the store at the
beginning it starts off in the
gravitational potential energy store so
to show that it's in a store I draw it
in a box like this now what type of
energy does it end up as so as it lets
go as I let go of it it moves so as it
moves it's in the kinetic energy store
again because it's a store I've drawn it
in a box like this so remember whenever
we have forces acting we need to have
and we need to show that it's
mechanically but to show this we show an
arrow going from our starting and
she store to our ending energy store and
above that arrow I just write
mechanically now what this shows is we
started with gravitational potential
energy store we've gone to the kinetic
energy store and we've done this
mechanically so whenever we've got
anything involving forces it's
mechanically okay I'm going to show you
an example when the transfer is
electrically so let's imagine that we've
got a battery powered fan so there's my
battery there goes in here's my little
fan right here so in in order for my fan
to work order for my fan to work I need
this this battery to be attached okay
so let's again think about the initial
store the starting store is chemical
energy energy store now again because
it's a store I put it in a box and I'm
thinking what is my ending store again
this fan is going to move around so I'm
going to get a cleaner transfer energy
into the kinetic energy store now
because this is transferred by
electrical charges flowing around the
surf as around the circuit my arrow it's
showing the transfer from one to another
it's going to have the words electric
the word electrically written above the
arrow so again this shows we started off
the chemical energy store we ended up
with a chemical energy store because
we've got charges move it it's been
transferred electrically two more to go
so whenever we've got heating
transferred by heating we need to have
something going from hotter to colder so
what I'm going to show you right now is
an example so let's say we've got this
saucepan which is here heated on the hob
okay so to begin with let's think about
the energy within the hob it starts off
as a thermal energy store now this often
confuses people because we're
transferring Internet into these water
molecules here so we're also
transferring it to a thermal energy
store it just so happens it's just in a
different
particular place so how have we got from
this thermistor to this thermistor the
answer is by heating because we've gone
from hotter to colder so finally the
last type of radiation that sorry the
last type of transferring energy is by
radiation so a nice example of this is
how the Sun heats up the air or heat
source up on earth now this isn't by
heating because in order for the the
heater in thermal energy for the Sun to
get to the earth it travels in waves so
radiation is whenever you have things
traveling in waves such as radiation
when it's to do with heat transfer and
also things like light so again we've
got thermal energy store to begin with
because that's the store of energy
thermal energy within the Sun we're
heating up the air particles on earth so
we've got thermal energy store on earth
right there and this time the way that
it's transferred is radiation so just to
summarize whenever you're showing energy
transfers you always start off by
writing one store the starting store and
putting it in a box and you write the
finishing store where does the energy
end up in another box what you then need
to do is draw an arrow between the two
boxes with it with an arrow going that
way to show that energy started off here
and it's ended up over here and above
the arrow
you need to write mechanically if is to
do with forces electrically if there's a
charge moving by heating if there's
energies moving from hotter to colder or
radiation
if waves are involved thank you very
much